what's up you guys it's Graham here so
welcome to my first ever podcast ever if
it that I've been I don't wanna say I'm
hosting it I mean you're mostly hosting
me but right
co-host and co-host there's no host I
don't like that it's good it's fine
podcasters are wrong let's keep going
let's go alrighty normally guys what I'm
gonna be doing it's doing a YouTube
video I would do that intro like 20
different times it's true 20th time I
would get so upset I'm like okay I'm
just using this it's true okay cool
alright the podcast yeah welcome to the
podcast so we'll do a little
introductions Graham you go first what
do you want me to say just you know
introduce you I mean everyone already
knows I am so pompous though is you I'll
introduce you and you introduce me okay
so Graham right here he's a 30 year old
I'm not gonna call him a real estate
agent because he mainly does YouTube
videos now but that's what he does he
makes YouTube videos on personal finance
and yeah that's pretty much it
that's what I do yeah almost two million
subscribers right yeah and that's crazy
another month exactly exactly the way
yeah
so I'm joke you want to introduce me
yeah go ahead so you're jack so jack is
the one that you see behind the scenes
who's been editing the phone calls if
you send an email to like the Graham
Stefan show or Graham Stefan business or
Graham Stefan mentorship we have so many
emails do you send an email to anyone
it's Jack who reads them in response
back to you guys or not responds back to
you this is Jack so I don't I don't see
a lot of the emails so anyway Jack Jack
is the guy behind the scenes and this is
his idea put me up to this so and Graham
and I are actually coming up on our
one-year anniversary very cute right
very cute yeah in like a couple of weeks
that'll make one year that I've been
working with him thank you thank you I
started off as a lowly fan and now I am
yeah you started off going through the
Facebook group emails yep so um so yeah
this is a beginning we're doing this and
first off I think a good activity for
the first ever podcast would be a hot
seat for Graham because obviously most
people are here for him okay so I've
prepared some questions for you are you
ready to hear me out all right so first
off I'd like to say
when you do your videos you seem to have
a pretty moderate opinion right like you
never really want to go astray or
extreme or anything do you think that
you're ever not true to yourself because
you're holding back to like you know
appeal to a larger audience sometimes
honestly opinions are completely
worthless I mean my opinion on certain
subjects is completely irrelevant to
looking at facts and research and data
like I could think something might
happen but I think I'll keep my opinion
out of it because all we could really
look at is the facts figures and the
data and the history and then I let
people come up with their own decision
that that has always been my go-to so
sure I have opinions I have things that
I don't purposely share but usually
that's for a reason I'd like people to
come up with their own opinions so you
do it mainly to be as accurate as
possible it's not really to appeal to a
larger audience or to pander no because
I like that people could go through my
videos and they can't say I was wrong I
don't like that they can't watch my
video and disagree with them because
it's like they're disagreeing with fact
right right I can't disagree with fact
they could say a certain thing about the
stock market I could well you know I
cited all of this research so you can't
go to me and say I'm wrong unless you're
calling you know everyone at Harvard who
did the studies you would you spent like
years of her life doing this yeah like
I'm researching the data so I put in the
time I show people what I think they
would want to hear or see and go from
there this is true Graham does a lot of
research hours it literally will be like
6 hours you know - even 10 hours of
research per videos yeah easy
yeah kudos to him thanks ok so second
question
let's see here if you weren't a finance
youtuber what kind of videos would you
make on YouTube that's a great question
thank you
thank you thank you Wow you know what I
originally this is like seven years ago
I use I wanted to prank videos I thought
would be so funny to do prank videos and
I actually came up with the idea and
this is before like anyone I'll start to
do this I was like a lot of these prank
videos would be so much easier if you
just hired actors but I thought like it
would be so easy to just hire actors and
go on like recur
a lot of these things right right viral
videos yeah I don't know and that's what
everyone's doing that's what everyone
think it's no longer me in that anymore
but I thought that would be like a fun
thing I'd want to do prank videos I
thought about I think like you know
music videos but like drum covers stuff
like that I think would be fun who
inspired you for the prank videos la vie
la was one of them yeah vite Ali would
be another one Josh paler Lynne a few
big ones I would say those there's so
many print overboard humor before
everything that happened with that
overboard what happened with over-over
my dad some issues had some personal
stuff come up and I think it leaked
itself into the channel unfortunately
and I think this is the content suffered
because of that don't you know just
tough stuff in general but yeah
overboard humor was another one there's
there's so many channels that I used to
watch back then to just pick five TV
what's another one
limitless exp was it limitless yeah exp
I think Vincent Valentine was another
one of them one of those guys those are
the these are guys who would just be in
Vegas just pulling little pranks like
harmless little prank yeah yeah that's
fine yeah but that's yes so I would say
probably pranks and then music so you
said that their personal stuff got into
the channel how big of a threat do you
think YouTube is just to for you know a
YouTube creators own mental health
because I feel like I see a lot of
YouTube creators doing a lot of videos
like about my anxiety about my
depression like do you think that
YouTube can spur that kind of like
mentality or it can make people you
think that the job is hard because a lot
of people like a very prideful that
their youtuber isn't like they love
their job but then I see a lot of videos
like that like yeah it's definitely
because your boss is an algorithm that
only rewards you if you keep posting and
each post has to be better than the last
and the way the algorithm works is that
if your video does well the next video
after that is going to do well too but
if your next video afterwards suffers
then the video following that is going
to suffer alongside with it so it's like
if the faster you run the faster the
treadmill goes so the
fasten you know the the more distance
you're covering but you right right you
can't just keep doing what you're doing
you have to continually push and do
better and better and better that takes
a toll on people even for me it's just
constantly figuring out that I think
would perform better than the last one
it's like right good only make so many
tops too about personal finance before a
lot of them become repetitive and if
there's no like if there's no news or
anything happening how do you how do you
bring people back into the channel it's
it's tough so yes so I think that's why
I just it becomes very time-consuming
and I think keeping that up you did I
definitely think it's something that you
can't sustain for like 20 30 years at
the current level right unless if you
have like a team behind you that are
doing all the backend stuff you got a
guy doing although there you go there
you go
so that that's why I think it's just
it's so much work and so much involved
that there's a high turnover rate I
think of people who do it for a few
years and then just burnout yeah that's
fair that's fair we've seen a lot of
youtubers go mainstream recently yeah so
that's interesting you say that let's
see if you could collab with anybody you
know I'm talking like anybody you want
you know it could be the biggest
youtubers that you could be like mr.
beast you know not even in the finance
like yeah my first go-to is Dave Ramsey
Dave Ramsey so would be in finance it's
interesting yeah that was my first if I
could collab with anybody would be Dave
if you could get anybody on the gram
Stefon show so I'm talking you know you
could get the president you could get
anybody you want
so Oh probably quick besides Dave Ramsey
I would love to have mr. beast and Danny
Duncan okay yeah and the other two guys
who I would love to have them on the
channel anybody any way Elon Musk okay I
don't know yeah I'm not gonna argue with
that that's fair that's fair okay on
Elon Musk what do you think about his
naming of his child was it what was it
know what yeah no no it's like x AE a 12
yeah yeah but like I think I read
somewhere that that's pronounced Kyle
because if you in in pronounced in Greek
those letters work out to be Kyle to is
like the LD
are you serious well I thought there was
something named Kyle so it's a meme
apparently oh wait meme accounts have
convinced people that Elon Musk and
Grimes's baby name is pronounced Kyle
yeah I didn't think that he would do
that so I haven't seen it actually like
written out new baby boy X I don't know
the AE I don't know I don't know Greek I
don't know no 8 yeah it's not like a
fighter jet or something like that wait
wait joy he identified the second
character is ash saying it was
pronounced ex ash shaked it's so
ridiculous it's yeah so there's no
confusion he's just letting the press
take off so you what do you think about
the name you like the name would I be so
rich to be able to name her kids
something like that right never gonna
have a normal life right like that so
you got it there's got to be able to
provide there's got to be a net worth
threshold threshold for you to go and
name a kid like that like was named
Apple like there's like an apple
something I grew I went to high school
with someone named Apple I think it's a
common name I don't know it was when its
Paltrow and they named their daughter
Apple well so you got it you gotta have
better Apple than like orange or
watermelon or something like has to be
blue ivy that's the kid's name that's a
name I don't even the more the more
money you have the what I like the more
wild the names oh that's smart that's my
a hundred million bucks you just you
know my mom is a is a kindergarten
teacher and she had a student in her
class named seven claw-like then it
literally spelled out se ven that's cool
yeah and like stranger things yeah
exactly exactly seven yeah all right so
let's move on to the next question here
all right Graham so we know your guilty
pleasure is all you can eat sushi what
is your real guilty guilty pleasure like
not with you know eating sushi or
anything like that it doesn't even have
to be with money but what would you say
you like spoil yourself with you
in there do you have a guilty pleasure
the drumset was something that I spent
money on the trunk the drumset was
something I got for myself it doesn't
have to be anything you spend money on
any glutton work for anything I mean
that's really what it is that's true
this guy works non-stop it yeah all
right all right that's I don't need much
on a leaky sushi for me is like a reward
at the Macdonald Macdonald dollar menu
is something that's that's another rule
board drum set was a splurge the the
reef aquarium is gonna be another
splurge but like like even on my
birthday like you know this like all I
wanted to do my just wanted to work I
just wanted like a normal work day
because like that's I that's what I'd
like waking up to like I'm excited to
wake up in the morning so I can get to
work so Graham and I will occasionally
go to McDonald's and when we do Graham
gets the same thing he gets to make
doubles okay Graham what do I get the
chicken I get to make chicken and I get
a McDouble yeah and it's called him
again I might bleep that out okay but
what you do is you pull apart the
McDouble and you have you know the meat
and the cheese and the bun on one side
meat cheese not bun on the other side
and you get the McChicken and you put it
inside and close it mmm what do you
think of that hey you know what Monday
well going Monday we'll go do that all
right cool you'll you'll try one yeah
they're delicious I'm telling you like
it's it's definitely worth it all right
cool yeah now let's talk about moving in
okay so what do you think cuz right now
I actually live with Graham in the guest
houses part right now what do you think
about me moving in do you think it went
smoother or more difficult than it you
know then you would have initially got
worried initially I'll be honest because
I I like hat like it's hard for me to
concentrate sometimes because I was
worried that like what if I need to work
in the back yard what if he can't keep
themselves busy enough is it gonna
interfere with me planning and like all
this right so I definitely went in
thinking like I just I I need my time
not to be distracted so I can plan and
it went smoothly I mean very just like
very effortlessly I know I'm missing out
on rents by not renting out that guest
house but overall I would say very
smoothly and it went I would say better
than expected good good I'm glad
um let's see here also about me moving
in one thing that you told me which I
was I was very careful about this you
wanted to make sure that you know a
friendship and business that we're not
really two things that like did I say
that yeah you did
and believe me like one of the things I
want to make sure I do is never like you
know encroach on like anything that you
know what's going on in your life but I
thought it was interesting you said that
and obviously makes sense and it was
something I I expected you to say
something like that yeah so what do you
think of it now since I've been here for
a while do you think that it's difficult
that you know we do have a friendly
relationship right you know what I mean
working with someone who's your friend
do you think that you ever hold back on
me do you think that you're not tough
enough on me uh no I don't think so
the thing is I I could probably always
ask for more so I would say there's a
few times where I'm like I very much
like I like to drop everything and just
get it done as fast as possible so there
are times where I would love for just
like let's drop everything work until
like two o'clock in the morning wake up
at six let's keep going right so it's
hard for me sometimes to pen like not
everyone is like that so you know I
would say that's my only things that
sometimes I'm like we got them all
anyway let's edit it as soon as possible
get it out like all the photos why all
the phone calls done in like five hours
we could do something else so right
right that's usually how I operate so I
would say overall though I think I'm
pretty straightforward when it comes to
that yeah I would agree on I would agree
with that you know okay so now what
we're gonna do is you're gonna need
three strengths three weaknesses or
however many you want what do you think
are my weaknesses and strengths and I'll
tell you yours okay this is dangerous I
mean you're my boss right like yeah uh
let's start with strengths I would say
very motivated okay
very persistent and takes criticism well
mmm say three strengths three weaknesses
the reason we tell you this before you
say it say the weakness the reason why I
take criticism well is because I'm
confident okay so if you tell me my
weaknesses be sure that it's
I would say the the the weaknesses not
being able to focus a hundred percent
you know that yeah I think sometimes are
there are things that need a little bit
more urgency that or maybe just not done
immediate but then again that's that I
wouldn't say that's a big thing no
that's fair I was about to say not
getting to things immediately but that's
the same thing I don't know there's
plenty of stuff you could pick from you
know lack of original thinking not
contributing enough yeah very punctual
face okay okay it's coming from you yeah
half of this guy's comments are just
that's funny
I don't know I don't care enough yeah
fair enough would you like to hear you
know what a lot more time to plan this
out I actually okay so I actually did
not think of anything for you so this is
all impromptu or whatever I recalled so
I think that one of your weaknesses
starting it off with weakness is I think
that you work too hard and you evolve
your life around money because I
remember hearing them one middle-ground
episode which I totally agree is like
and also someone in one of my classes
actually UCSB they said that whatever
you warship you become a slave to so you
you know you worship money and you
worship you know your entrepreneurial
endeavors but now you're kind of a slave
to it and since you you hold it at such
high regard you'll never really be truly
satisfied with money and progress and
productivity it's at this point it's
it's less about money I think it's just
the byproduct of I like working and I
like seeing the numbers go up and I like
yeah but now you become a slave to it
you you chase it and I think that you'll
never be you know truly truly satisfied
oh I would agree with that okay that's
good yeah so I think that that was
probably you know it's a weakness of
yours I think a strength I think that I
mean you're extremely honest you you're
a pleasure to do business with like yeah
I know for a fact I'll never get
shortchanged and I think we both have
really really good mutual trust another
weakness of yours is you're too trusting
I think that you probably let people
take advantage of your walk on you I
don't think so I think so because you
remember we went to you know in that one
tree
and you were too scared to ask for a
check you're not confrontational and as
a businessman you have to be
confrontational okay we went on a trip
and you don't need to go why oh oh no
he's right he's right no we don't need
to go into details but very interesting
so that's one thing I don't think you're
confrontational okay all right that's
fair
yeah which is fair one of my most
unattractive traits is my parents
sometimes they'll order for me when we
go for dinner we can leave that part out
that yeah so that was a string that was
awareness okay I mean overall I think
that you obviously I think you're a
powerhouse like I think that you do you
do well in whatever you apply yourself
to and I think that's good I think
that's probably just because of your
work ethic in mentality fair enough okay
um another weakness I want to say I
can't I can't - perfect you see Graham
makes me leave my shoes at his door and
at first I kind up my shoes to wear when
I walk in yours you choose the door yeah
which at first I thought was a weakness
but now it actually makes a lot of sense
yeah yeah because recently I've been
kind of putting my shoes at the doors my
guess is yeah so um another thing when
did you enjoy YouTube the most because I
I think it's probably not now because
now it's a career and it used to be a
hobby I don't know I part of me feels
like now you think you enjoy it now yeah
but now it's your career and people say
when your hobby becomes your career then
you enjoy less no um I would say my
favorites I would say in the very
beginning for the first 20,000
subscribers I would say and now yeah I
would say the middle part was a lot of
us like the grind but now it seems like
well it's very much in a wave of the
algorithm like when the algorithm is in
your favor you love it when the
algorithm is going down and your videos
are not getting views you hate it so now
I'm loving it right now because the
algorithm has been the best right so
obviously I'm having more fun with it
now because I'm like you're putting in
work and then you're seeing this great
outcome and it makes you feel like wow I
did something great you know people
really like it it's a good message and
in the beginning it was really just
because it was it was new and every
subscriber was WOW another person
subscribed the first thousand was a big
milestone for me the first 10,000 was a
huge milestone for me
and then I remember hitting 20 ambulate
wow that's like that was that was not
right right right and that was the point
- or like hitting you know a few
thousand views in a day it was insane so
that for me was pretty big good to know
I'm glad that you're enjoying it now
this is good so I was listening to
another podcast and someone asked a
really interesting question the question
was since you've become successful does
anyone ever come to you with terrible
business ideas like people that you've
you know you've known in the past and
now they're reaching out to you and
they're like need alone okay so to two
things
in terms of terrible business ideas yes
believe it or not I don't want to call
anybody out it was don't have to say who
they are you could say the idea I don't
know the person came up to me and I
don't want to give away his business
idea but he had he had this idea and
[Music]
wanted me to go down to the parking lot
in his truck because he wanted to show
me his product and I mean if it could
perform as it was it was basically like
like a it was a type of adhesive
basically we'll call it it it was a type
of adhesive and if it could perform the
way he says it could perform it would be
great but I just he made these claims it
sounds so just like so out there like it
was stronger than steel and like and it
made me and it just just the vibes kind
of got me off it's just like it sits in
his it's in his truck right right all
right and just like he wants he needs
money like he wanted like 200 and how
long ago is this a few months ago really
yeah yeah I didn't know anything about
that no I mean it was just you know a 10
minute thing and then you know but
sometimes because he's a fan of the
channel so I didn't want to say like no
so I heard him out but then it kept
going and going and going I don't want
to you know okay right right right
no but that was it fair enough fair
enough
yeah um final question that I've
prepared is businesses when you were
younger when you were younger there any
businesses that you started up or you
you tried to start up now looking in you
know hindsight they actually were not
multiple but I never actually pursued a
lot of them - where to start
um one I wanted to make so the first one
I bought man I should have done this one
in high school I bought the domain odd
jobs com whoa believe it or not and it
was a high school business project and
odd jobs was basically a Craigslist for
people to post up odd jobs that they
want to get done and people could make
an account and do those odd jobs like if
someone wants their garage cleaned out
he posed on odd jobs com
someone could go and clean out your
garage for a specified price and it
could be anybody and then that person
the worker would have their profile on
there and people can review them right
right
so it basically it turned into later
what was what it was turned into
TaskRabbit
and then they sold that for a lot of
money so I mean how they pursued that
sure but your so only good ideas ever
from you so yeah so that was one of them
and I let the domain expire and so yeah
and then someone else bought it I should
have kept it that was an odd jobs com
yeah it was great
another one was I bought the domain art
sleeve I don't know why just art sleeve
calm and now it's bought I don't know I
I don't think I ever renewed it but I
bought art sleeve calm
what kind of business so you turn it so
what that was supposed to be that now
turned into Etsy oh nice this was this
would have been in 2008 is when I did
this I'm sure I stole you can still have
no outline for art sleeve Oh that'll be
cool but yeah art sleeve was one of them
there were a whole bunch I came up with
all these let's see if I type an art
sleeve this would be a blast in the past
let's see if art sleeve alright so just
find it all right you found art sleeve
so like I came up with all of this on
Microsoft Word so I came up with this
whole outline literally I'm like so art
sleeve and then you could search for
like painting sculptures by artist name
and then it would basically be so this
is before like I guess this is like
basically like a MySpace thing cuz this
is
this was over 10 years ago that this was
done so yeah sir like you would have the
user a profile picture people can rate
them views their featured artwork they
can have like blogs galleries reviews
guestbook for people to sign that so
this was a good idea if you pursued this
this could've taken on so anyway so yeah
so that was one of them arts leaves calm
the other one that I never pursued that
I really wanted to do I wanted to come
up with a free cell phone plan where
instead of you know when you call a
phone it's like it rings it yeah imagine
if you get a free cell phone so you
wouldn't have to pay any sort of like
monthly data or like anything like that
so you don't have to pay like 30 40
bucks a month but instead anytime you
make an outgoing call you'll hear an ad
for like 10 15 seconds and then the call
goes through whoa that's so I figured
you know like or or when people call you
let's just say instead of hearing the
you know it's ringing or you know how
people have a ring back tone or a play
some classical music or something
imagine if a person calls you and they
just hear an ad until you pick up the
phone that's pretty smart people and you
know if you're receiving calls maybe you
could even if you receive a lot of calls
you could probably monetize it and you
know you could like wait like for like
three or four rings wait a while and
then finally like answer to get them
long a play time on the ads so you
either get a free cell phone that all
you have to do to make a call is listen
to an ad fine or you can get paid like
imagine if people call you and you could
just give me now now you would have to
figure out some way of just not like
manipulating that and hiring call
centers all right right right I think
realistically it's just a free cell
phone plan where you can make as many
calls as you want within the United
States but it's just you listen to an ad
before the call goes through not a bad
idea so I yeah I came up I know I got a
business plan in there but basically I
was one of those kids where it's like
okay so there's 300 million people in
United States if we can kids 1% of those
people and we make an average of you
know 15 cents a day you know you know
all of this yeah yeah
based on that and that was my that was
my pinch was just was just that like if
we could miss him a people make this
amount right right I started looking
into it and it was just it was I felt so
over my head and just like I had this
idea it's hard but I was like where do I
start
how do I get advertisers I think it was
like 18 years old I was like what do I
do
never pursued it there were two other
ones one was called the truth intel.com
and that was a website I wanted to make
a Yelp for people I'd like to see if
they're like a good or bad person okay I
think I've seen like a black mirror or
something on this but something like
that yeah but this is made this one
again this was like almost ten years ago
truth in telecom where and this one we
actually have if you'd go to truth in
Telecom I just don't know if I want to
promote truth in Telecom because we're
not pursuing it so in in hindsight you
think it's a bad idea a terrible idea to
just like see how good of a person
people oh yes if you had an account what
do you think your rating would be - any
influence from you know subscribers or
anything like that just the people you
meet on the street what do you think
your your rating would be out of fun day
for four and a half out of 1000 at a
fine oh okay so you think you're like
okay so maybe 80% yeah I think it's
funny it's funny everyone's done things
in the past they haven't been proud of
so anyway so I thought it was like if
the Yelp for businesses there should be
a Yelp for people and it should be a bad
person yes okay but here's the issue
is that we started getting into it and a
few things one is that people will very
rarely go and write a positive review
usually the people online if they
actually take the time to review
something it's gonna be negative like
you have to have such extreme feelings
to actually take the time to review
somebody so my thinking right off the
bat is that predominantly it's gonna be
overwhelmed with negativity it's good
right
the next thing was that there's no
fact-checking there's nothing - for me
to go on and like I don't like this
person so I'm gonna write a really bad
review
there's no filter to that and once you
begin moderating comments on the
internet you're assumed to then be
publishing or endorsing information so
this is something I wasn't aware of but
you could be a website and remain
completely neutral and be completely
avoid void of lawsuits if you don't
moderate comments if just whatever
submitted is submitted you don't option
but as soon as you start moderating any
comments or restricting what could be
published or removing stuff then you're
endorsing everything else and then you
can be liable interesting so I didn't
know that so you know if something gets
published on the site and it's obviously
fraudulent and it's obviously not true
and it's so ridiculous we can't go in
and remove it and you know just you
wouldn't want it to be damaging to the
person or you wouldn't want right right
right
if I wrote a really terrible thing about
you and that you lose a job now or
something happens I couldn't you know I
couldn't you know feel good about myself
knowing that my website led to something
like that you know we did do a mock-up
site that that we promoted around our
friend group and it actually got like it
for some reason it caught on in like
this other country so so so here's what
happened so what we ended up doing is we
we went through like 50 to 100 friends
and we start promoting it on Facebook
and we got a decent amount of traction
for people making like little profiles
and kind of like having fun so you had
to make a profile so you couldn't I like
just like see someone on the street like
that guy's face looks you know so nice
to begun I would have to make a profile
on you and then so even if I didn't even
say it's okay for me to be there like no
the way we had in sections anyone could
go on and make a profile about anybody
so I could make a profile about you
upload your picture put your name I can
just say whatever agents footing you
want and so we did this and what ended
up happening was that we had our friend
and he had a very unique last name that
not many people have that last name so
we made it like a funny little post
about him
just funny stuff but it was kind of wild
so like we're friends so you know how
friends is kind of like joke around with
each other so anyway we wrote some
stupid stuff about him just jokingly
knowing that we're all friends you know
ha yeah yeah
didn't realize that that showed up
within like a few weeks as the number
one result on Google when you typed in
his last name and his dad has a
construction company with that same last
name so guess what his review came up
first before his dad's construction
company so the dad was furious over that
because when people googled the
construction you know I was almost about
seeing our friends profile would come up
first with our little joking things yeah
very upset about that so we took that
down but yeah but for some reason we
would log in and see like people have
been creating profiles like some other
country and we're like how did they get
because we never promoted it there right
no anyway so it was that was one of
those ideas that got shut down that's
funny you say that that reminds me of
something that happened within my friend
group in high school I had two friends
and one of them asked the other friend
can I can I sell you on Craigslist as a
joke yeah so you know the other friend
was like yeah sure I don't care like
whatever you do and he didn't think he
would actually like make the listing and
my friend made the listing and actually
sold like like tried to sell this other
guy on Craigslist and pulled up a
picture of him when he was like 7 so
this is where it turns bad yeah he he
posted this on Craigslist a picture of
you know the other guy when he was like
7 years old and he said oh this is like
young little like whatever he only needs
like a pint of water a day and stuff
like that and like basically yeah so he
he was saying like he don't need to
treat him well whatever like that it was
like a it was a bad situation right but
like back in the day like we thought
that was funny right because you know
obviously I can't mature and stuff like
that and and yeah the listing got taken
down everyone forgot about in three
months later we're at a track event and
like the sergeant of like some crazy
like chieftain of police or something
like that comes over and he's like are
you so and so and he was like yeah and
then he's like you got to come with me
and apparently they had launched an
investigation and they had been
investigating for about three months to
find out who is trying to sell this
person on Craigslist
yeah they found it out and and yeah lo
and behold like no one got in any
trouble but the officer was really
really pissed because obviously a waste
of like you know resources stuff from
the police department and yeah there was
a little bit of animosity between those
friends after that obviously they've
settled things now but like crazy huh
Wow two other ideas I came up came up
with by the way that I just remembered
one was an Airbnb for parking spaces
like you know in Los Angeles smart
parking is so hard to come by and I
remember going around Venice and
especially as a real estate agent like
you want to show a property and like
Venice or like say you know Santa Monica
you see they're all permit parking can't
find anywhere to park but imagine an app
that you can pull up on your phone and
basically pay per minute to park in
someone's parking spot these are good
ideas I don't know why you know you
never really dude San Francisco they
failed no because they couldn't find
enough homeowners that would agree to do
something like that now I kind of get it
I I'm sure I have it all my email to
okay it's if you have like a two to
three million dollar house you know
you're not caring if you yeah hey you
know I bucks five bucks an hour for
parking I thought that it would make
sense for someone's driveway during like
8:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m. if they're at
work anyway why not make twenty thirty
bucks right away so that was something I
thought of so so this we we tried making
a truth Intel by the way mobile app
where you could swipe your friends so
it's integrated on Facebook so you could
go on the app tell them what all of your
friends from Facebook and then swipe I
love that image that just says is Carla
honest yeah but it but it's a rating
system so basically it'll ask you
questions about the person you could say
yes or no and you could go through your
Facebook friends and then like it's
Carla honest oh my god so we put down
here she is so annoying stop posting
pictures of your food watch what you say
to her she can't keep a secret for
beautiful friends I don't understand
like did you think this was like funny
when you're a kid because I think it's
funny now like I added
look but you could see like it's Karla
honest you can see 12 people said no six
people when you were coming up with that
idea specifically did you think that it
was actually like gonna be a successful
business or anything did you think that
what you were doing with your friends
was funny though oh we had a blast I
mean this was this was us getting
together like twice a week hanging out
coming up with ideas thinking we're
gonna be you know billionaires that
that's what we thought hmm do you have
any questions for me that you'd like to
address you could put me in the hot seat
and feel free to ask me anything no
filter I'm good without planning I don't
know I know what comes to the top of
your head when is this gonna be posted I
mean that that's like the number see
that's the thing you just you don't stop
thinking about work all the time do you
think they'll ever change from that well
you know I seem to go in these these
phases where for like a few years
they'll be really hyper into it then a
few years off and if you use really into
it a few years office so it's on the
scale of years it's not like weeks or
months because it seems like you know
for real estate I was really really
really like interested in that for the
first like five six years went through a
period for a few years where I was just
like ah got back into it and YouTube
came up but still like at such a young
age making like that much money did you
really feel like air like it's hard for
me to ya know when you start doing the
same thing for a while it started
feeling every deal was about the same
this showings are the same houses were
the same yeah I still I still was
excited about it but it went through a
phase of just you know I was just I was
tired of being at someone's beck and
call all the time and I was tired of
just like a p.m. would come around and
like oh I know I got it like pick up my
phone and go to a showing right now I
don't know where I didn't like that I
couldn't I couldn't plan around it you
know like a lot of that was so spur of
the moment
if becoming a real estate agent was
never really a thing do you think that
you would have ever started making
YouTube videos yeah yeah because I'd
wanted to make youtube videos for quite
some time
so you think that you still regardless
of whether or not you were a real estate
agent you would have made youtube videos
maybe I don't know feels they gave me
something to talk about on YouTube right
I don't know what I would have done
besides that it originally was just to
be I was gonna be a drama you know
well first was in bed
banker but I didn't want to go to the
school for that I didn't have the grades
so that that was out drummer I just I
didn't want to be the starving musician
living in a van on the fair because
there's some great drummers out there
I don't know IIIi would have probably
come up with some app some website you
know I was really really interested in
that what's fascinating to me is you
always say that you were really bad at
school like you had like well like a 2.6
GPA or yeah something like really low by
honors in did you not try in school were
you not motivated because so stupid
you thought school itself was stupid but
it's so stupid so you think if you
really tried you could've done better I
don't know I just because I mean you're
pretty like eloquent in the way that you
speak in like I think that year your
overall like I think you're pretty like
intelligent so I couldn't understand
chemistry I couldn't really understand
math um English I just didn't see the
point there's a lot of stuff I just
didn't see the point so you didn't try
and where your parents never like urging
you like come on what is this report
card restream you know C's or whatever
not really I think beyond you know at a
certain point they're just like it is
what it is they can't really yeah it's
so much stupid like I didn't want to
learn poetry in English like I just sit
there and just be angry because it's
like this is stupid I don't want to I
don't want to do this
the sitting chemistry it's just like I
don't want to learn chemistry yet it's
like what am I gonna do with this same
with math we're very practical yeah it's
like I only thought about is how is this
gonna help me make money that's that's
it so even at a young age you always
still had to make money mentality no so
you always wanted to like you had the
goal set in mind of becoming really
wealthy yeah it's interesting even if
what if you were to do something you
were never passionate about like a job
that you you really didn't want to do it
I tried working it but you made a lot of
money here we go Gold Line international
never said that before gold liner that
was a job that I worked at barely out of
high school that was that was what I
thought was gonna get me into like the
investment world was Gold Line
international I started doing data entry
with them and I hated it could not stand
it but I was how much were you making a
minimum wage like it was either between
eight and twelve so it wasn't even that
it's like it wasn't great no but the the
goal was with that is that they were
going to start me off doing
entry and a mailroom and then move me up
from that into the it was into the
shipping so it was like data entry
mailroom the bottom of the barrel then
he got into shipping which was like
right above that then you got into gosh
there was something else above shipping
that was just slightly better and then
after that maybe it was a customer
service or there's a lot of steps
essentially buddy but but the end goal
would be to be what's called an account
representative and what you would do is
an account representative is you'd have
a list of numbers of people who have
inquired by gold in the past or precious
metals or numismatic coins and you would
sit there all day making calls to
clients trying to sell them at the top
that's the top that doesn't sound like
the top that sounds like grunt work
no no because you're paid on Commission
so some of those dudes were making like
200 grand a year but obviously didn't
after that you have like right right
okay so I wanted to be the account
representative or the account exec you
tell the marketer yeah which at the time
I saw that I thought that was the most
like glamorous glitzy because like
everyone in the back and I worked in the
back office everyone in the back office
would be like a third beckon call right
right and have some dude like they would
wave the sheet in the air when they did
a deal and like someone would have to go
and run that over to processing in the
back in a process the order and there
would be like someone going around and
like if they needed coffee or something
give him coffee and they're like the
kings yeah and like everyone and it
seemed like there was this big divide
between the front office and the back
off at the back office people were like
these these you know literally yeah and
there are many people you can see them
like drive the Mercedes oh I wanted to
be that you know so whole like system a
whole like why is it was very corporate
I hated it though but yeah that was that
I hated so that that to me was so
impactful that I could never do a job
that I hated because I would never want
to return to that again it was so awful
the first day I liked it and then after
that I had load that I hated life so a
question I remember hearing one time
that I thought was really interesting
would you sit in a blank white room for
eight hours a day but be making $200,000
obviously before you started making
money in real estate in YouTube when you
were at that point in your life would
you have accepted a job like that sit in
a blank white room for eight hours a day
doing nothing but still walking home
with a big paycheck probably you would
and do they need any Tina for us yeah
yeah fair enough I feel like a lot of
people would probably try it out and
then after a while they like to screw
this this is Terrence there would you do
it for one hundred thousand one hundred
thousand okay it's fair that's bad I
mean even now like I'm sure there's a
dollar amount where you would you could
pay me to be in a wife room for a day
I'm sure there's an amount I think we
all have an amount that we would do that
for it do you think sleep is a waste of
time no no Steve is the one thing for me
I just need it if I'd if I don't get to
bed by a certain time then I'm just I'm
a wreck the next day think about sleep
though because it's it's eight hours of
time per day depending on how much they
sleep that's just like nothing I think
of a way you could monetize sleep is
there any way that you can make money
off of sleep off obviously you can live
stream yourself sleeping there's gonna
be people watching that would if I set
up a webcam on me in bed sleeping there
would be people to watch it oh yeah Oh
guaranteed so I was watching a live
stream on Twitch and there's this guy
that went like sleeping and stuff and
there was a donation box and if you
donated a certain amount people came in
like physical people that were taking
care of him when he was sleeping and
they would do stuff to him so I was like
fifty dollars shoot a paintball at him
like a hundred dollars tase him like two
hundred dollars like no there was like
ten dollars like text to talk so like
they you know people would type stuff
and it blast it and wake him up but like
know there was like tasers and stuff and
I wouldn't be opposed you know if I can
make enough you and me asleep sleep and
let people watch you let's say it's like
two thousand dollars at night I mean
yeah no I mean yeah don't even like I'm
sleeping anyway if a what if you do omit
something embarrassing that you like
fart or something when you're like
sleeping it the audios gonna be turned
off I don't know so you turn the audio
maybe I don't know I'm gonna make sense
yeah I guess there's you can you can say
if you paid me ten million a year I
would sit you know you know
white room for eight hours a day for no
YouTube so you'd have to take a year
hiatus on my tips that would be worth it
wait wait no 10 million a year no no it
wouldn't be worth it I would say it was
it would have to be like 20 20 maybe 30
million dollars and you do I know
YouTube where would I go Grimm what
would I do
I'll pay it is just you know just watch
out because something in your break you
know 30 million bucks you could come
back and like have a crazy like what's
up guys I made 30 million in one year
and watch it I guess my biggest concern
that would be just mentally going crazy
and then because I because that that
might just be enough to screw you up and
then you're never the same afterwards
it's like going insane from sitting it
is not like what insane asylums are yeah
you're not getting paid for that it
might okay fine you could count how much
you're making from I don't know I just
don't know the effects of isolation for
eight hours a day every lose it every
single day the hard part would be if you
don't do it for an entire year you get
nothing so like if you get to day 300 oh
yeah that's what it would have to be
yeah it's either you get all of it or
nothing that's crazy
no yeah that would be a really
interesting concept I would probably do
it I bet honestly I bet most people
would do it I think a lot of people
don't like their job and would rather
sit in a white room for eight hours a
day with just completely deprived of all
of their senses eight hours a day just
time pass things time passing that would
feel like but but then again could you
sleep no yet so you have to be fresh off
of like eight hours of sleep you have to
be like as at your most hyper self with
nothing I don't you might mentally go go
crazy oh you probably would because I I
think humans are not designed to be that
I think honestly what I think would
happen is that you would you would get
very depressed you and I think you would
have a crisis that's what that's what I
think a little crisis in there yeah and
I think every day would get worse I
think you would battle severe depression
doing it and I think coming out of that
you'd probably have pee
est PTSD so like you couldn't get into
like a white room for an entire year
you're talking about let's say you know
if you live to 81 80th of your life was
spent in complete isolation for eight
hours day you're gonna wake up after
that when that is over and just be
paranoid like going back to that we're
like you're gonna be paranoia I'm out of
it it's gonna seem like a bad that's so
hard for me to actually picture because
I feel like the entire time I was in
that you know I would be in that white
room I would you be thinking about like
oh my god I'm like making this much
money you know maybe the beginning but
like every time I walk into a room and
it's like oh why I just be thinking
about dollar bills like if you look at
the hedonic treadmill after about two
months or so making that amount of money
is gonna seem completely normal and
they're just gonna hate it first two
months you could probably do it but
you'll get used to it that's interesting
to get used to things very quickly so
you see you'd say you're 100% used to
your current income do you ever do you
ever like sit back and just think like
wow this is insane yeah it's hard not to
lose perspective it's really hard
because because now I view things in
terms of like how many days is this
gonna cost me to pay for like how many
hours is this gonna cost to pay and
that's not a healthy way to think of
things because because now when you make
so much money it's just you know you
could buy this car two days two days
worth of work and then you know it
doesn't really show the context of just
how much money it actually is so what
I'm thinking is Graham wants to get an
aquarium okay and this aquariums gonna
cost like how much Graham 25 grand 25
grand
you heard it here and this aquarium
Graham has been thinking about getting
for how long now probably 10 years so
those 10 years that grams worth in 10
years I have not had an aquarium since
that 7 so if you sign that value to your
time and think about all the stress or
whatever thinking like oh my god this is
gonna put me in like financial ruin you
know what I mean like all of that if you
assign a value to that do you think that
it's equal that $25,000 probably but I
also and look at 25 grand and I sigh I
it's hard for me to to conceptualize
that because I see 25 grand is that
that's a lot of sushi right that's a lot
like when I was 18 that would be a lot
of work I would never have spent that so
I don't know it
just I see that as a lot of money on
things like I am so nitpicky of just
like I won't buy the more expensive
coffee creamer so I could save like you
know a dollar right or not even buy
generic Ram brand cream sheets so I
could save you know dollar fifty so I'm
looking at all these dollars in dollar
50s and I think 25 grand you know that's
twenty five thousand times would be
doing that so I'm like it's part of me
thinks what's the point to me going and
trying to save a dollar here and there
when it just blow it on an aquarium I
think that you're for gravity frugality
really like stresses you out I don't
know it puts it in perspective and it's
just it's a lot of money to spend I
don't know you know I think it'll be
it'll it would be a good decision but
it's like do I spend that much money or
do I just get a smaller aquarium and
don't need to reinforce the floors it
was like is it is it gonna be just as
good I don't know it's also a big
commitment on something where it's like
I hope I enjoyed as much as I did when I
was 16 I think I will but I think if you
wanted it for this long it's a pretty
safe bet that you'll really like it Lee
so which should we just wrap it up yeah
yeah so you want you want to do the
answer you want me to do the other job I
mean I feel like I'll start it and you
can sign it off so thank you guys so
much for watching we actually haven't
even mentioned the name of this podcast
I think they were gonna name it the
millionaire and this student I think it
just really wraps up a really
interesting dynamic you know of course
gran being very successful and then me
you know being not yeah just a complete
failure so you know if you didn't notice
I'm a student I go to University of
California Santa Barbara and yeah that
that's pretty much I study economics
cool store brah
thank you so yeah any suggestions for a
title I mean we may as well be open to
suggest I think we should probably name
this to begin like the Graham Stefon
podcast in the very beginning and then
we could shift from there yeah
he's cast a voter poll or something yeah
we'll do that so guys if you have any
names for this love if you actually got
to this point you listen to the whole
thing let me know I'd be I'd be really
excited to hear if people watch the
whole thing
so yeah because this is gonna be posted
on YouTube I don't know where you're
gonna be listening to this if you're on
YouTube or if there's a like button to
be smashed make sure to smash whatever
like button this is posted on this is
the first smash like smash smash like
button on the podcast
also make sure to add I don't know if
you want to Instagram plug sure JLS seob
why don't add a status both on Instagram
and lastly if you guys want out
subscribe obvious right right I get your
two free stocks down below in the
description for people enjoying the
mentorship group we meet twice a week
every Thursday and Sunday you do a zoom
call with me and so that's fun so yeah
link to that is down below in
description to you and I just do that so
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time